you got one month buddy you got one
month don't use it don't do it Scott
there's a school
there are you allowed to be around
children anywhere children would be
we're taking a look at the top body cam
moments of the last month from an
officer involved shooting to a political
candidate threatening a cop and a sex
offender found sleeping under a piano in
a Catholic Church remember I told you
was going to get crowded we don't need
it to be like
this you just dro the knife right where
you're at we're good we begin in Denver
where police were called to A Whole
Foods Market on September 19th at about
6:15 that evening an off-duty officer
inside the store reported seeing a man
who was quote out of it the suspect was
later identified as 33-year-old Latif
Robinson investigators say the the
off-duty cops spoke to Robinson but he
didn't answer minutes later he went
behind the deli counter and grabbed a
butcher style knife what's your name
bro what's your name just talk to me CH
out as First Responders attempted to
negotiate with Robinson they say he
pointed the blade into his chest later
he grabbed a different knife body camera
video captures officers on the scene
discuss the situation staff that just
walked toward staff back
and ask them make sure yeah there's a
backside First Responders call for
Robinson to drop the knife as they
attempt to deescalate the
situation so he's already said we're the
real bullets I don't want him to charge
better be popping that
steps got all day come talk to us but
minutes into the negotiation Robinson
still refuses to drop the weapon
remember I told he was going to get
crowded we don't need it to be like
this you just dro the knife right where
you're at we're good need to
go let's talk let's have a conversation
guys all finally he takes a step forward
with the knife still in hand that's when
gunshots ring out NOP no one was injured
in the gunfire but Robinson was tased he
was later taken into custody on
suspicion of felony menacing now Denver
PD says it's working with the District
Attorney's office and Mental Health
Resources to determine possible
treatment options for Robinson heading
east now to Oklahoma where a student
finds a convicted sex offender sleeping
under a piano at a Catholic Church you
sleeping under a piano
then you ran into the bathroom it
happened on October 19th in Enid
Oklahoma about an hour and a half north
of Oklahoma City there a student found
44-year-old Michael steel a convicted
sex offender sleeping underneath the
piano at St Joseph Catholic school so
where he was he was over
here he was right here under there
bolted
and went into the bathroom the following
day police officers responded to the
church and zeroed in on steel as the
suspect but the camera that they have is
right there the other way and it didn't
catch him uh so right now I have was M
Michael steel was the Michael Steel's
the suspect on this one he's a big black
dude no he's white later body camera
video shows officers arresting steel are
you willing to answer questions I'm
willing to have a discussion with you
are you willing to answer questions sure
some questions maybe not all of
them Miranda
red so you don't think you were anywhere
you weren't supposed to be I'd like to
know where they say I was supposed to
well you tell me where you were or you
weren't supposed to
be like I sleep at the Walmart parking
lot and I was check last night I was
checked in Northwest yeah before that
where were you
sleeping between love
in Walmart so you weren't say you
weren't sleeping anywhere downtown steel
then denies going into the church at all
what are they saying I
was I want to
know so you were at the Catholic
church I didn't sleep at the Catholic
Church you were there you were there
Thursday night there's a school
there are you allowed to be around
children anywhere children would
be I was talking to V yes or
no I already know the answer
so you have anything on you that's do
you have anything on you that's going to
be me stick me on camera steel never
admits to staying at the church you
sleeping under a
piano then you ran into the
bathroom and I I know you uh I know you
hang around the churches cuz the other
day said you were driving around the
churches and you didn't see a bunch of
Catholics or you saw more of one
denomination investigators say steel was
able to get into the church through an
unlocked door he's now charged with
failing to comply with sex offender laws
switching now to New York state where a
political candidate and former cop is
caught on body camera video threatening
an officer you right no you won't yeah I
will the incident happened on October
20th in Evans New York about 30 minutes
outside of buffalo video shows patrolman
Scott dejon responding to a car crash
when Mike Mulo approaches Mulo who once
worked as a police Lieutenant is now
running as a republican candidate for
Town
supervisor
hey is but is notle because he thinks
he's entitled from my daddy and me I'm
in the middle of this Deon later told
local TV stations the confrontation
stemms from an incident between himself
and mul's nephew you got one month buddy
you got one month don't use it don't do
it Scott well somebody better talk to
him he he's he's he he's no different
than you were as a kid go he's no
different than you were as a kid go do
do it do what just go just go just go
you got a month left all right got ath
okay the video ends as dejon accuses
Mulo of threatening an
officer guy yeah I
know and and then what
huh then what I don't know what right
there threatening officer right there
yeah I know you didn't you didn't think
of that did you I don't care Scott well
don't care you're going to mulu faced a
charge of harassment in the second
degree but the Evans police department
has since announced charges will not be
filed against him at least right now
that takes us to Wisconsin where a
suspect is now accused of dragging a
police officer when he sped off mid
traffic
stop
it happened on October 6 in Wawa toosa
Wisconsin just outside of Milwaukee
that's where officers pulled over
26-year-old Robert job who had a warrant
out for his arrest make your approach
you focus on him if it takes off I'll
handle the radio for that okay you're
going to call the coms yep okay sound
good dash camera video shows officers
approach job's vehicle aware that he may
make a break break for it he does just
that after four officers surround either
side of his
car video shows as Joe pulls away he
takes one of the officers with him
dragging the man for a few seconds
before he's set free after that the
police Chase
Begins
you good minutes later officers catch up
with job who ends up driving the wrong
direction against oncoming traffic
during his escape attempt back right
back left tires
out losing lost back left
tire wrong Lan of traffic continue East
he lost another tire as officers call
out that job's vehicle has flat tires he
ditches the car and tries to escape on
foot dash camera video shows an officer
slam his squat into park and Chase job
on
foot body camera video from another
responding officer shows the cops
tracking down job into a corridor the
back Courtyard stop your
get as officers catch up with job he
screams out before getting tased get out
the the after that the officers put job
in cuffs and call out the arrest on
their
radios keep
broadcasting driver in custody in the
back corner south of Appleton
one in Cody and the
car for an
update driver in custody we're in a back
quter T are
deployed all officers are good job is
now charged with second degree
recklessly endangering safety and
obstructing an officer at the time of
his arrest he was already on Doc
supervision for armed robbery and
fleeing an officer that was a look at
the top body camera videos from this
month for more car chases officer
involved shootings and all the latest
body and dash camera video make sure to
subscribe to lawn crime Network on
YouTube reporting for law crime I'm
Sierra gese